welcome to the first advance the lesson
in the journey into cryptography series
these lessons come out of key questions
that viewers have asked after watching
the entire series and in this case the
question by Norwood Paul was I would
like to hear more on prime factorization
the math exercise of it was cool and
it's fun to see an application here so
that's what we are going to do and just
to recap in the series we introduced
public key cryptography and we looked at
one construction our a and remember RSA
depended on one fact which was given the
number n it is hard to find the prime
factorization of n and when n grows very
very very large it takes a long time to
break it down into its prime factors so
not only prime factorization but RSA
also depended on it being easy
so remember factorization is hard and
we'll get into what hard and easy mean
but it takes a long time for a large
input it has to be easy to just generate
a prime if you recall an RSA Alice had
to generate two random Prime's and then
multiply them together to get in and to
be able to do those you must be able to
at least do the following which was
given some number X can you just tell me
if X is prime or not prime which is
composite so this is kind of the core
question that norwood paul asked that's
where we're going to begin given x is x
prime or composite and we'll build from
there and this defines our prime
adventure and we're going to continue
now with some quotes
we'll return back to 1770 and look at
what Leon Hart Euler said at the time
mathematicians have tried in vain to
discover some order in the sequence of
prime numbers but we have every reason
to believe that there are some
history's which the human mind will
never penetrate okay and thirty years
later here's a quote from Gauss the
problem of distinguishing prime numbers
from composite numbers and resolving
composite numbers into their prime
factors is known as one of the most
important and useful in arithmetic all
methods have been all methods that have
been proposed thus far are either
restricted to very special cases or are
so difficult that they try the patient
patience of even the practiced
calculator the dignity of science itself
seems to require that every possible
means be explored for the solution of a
problem so elegant and so celebrated Wow
so these two great thinkers have really
set the stage for the challenge ahead of
us and now I'm going to fast forward to
2010 and show you a paper that came out
of the RSA competition which is a
competent competition that no longer
runs but the purpose of the competition
was to put out a large number and say
can anyone factor it so in 2010 this
winning team factored a 768 bit number
and that means it was a 232 digit number
if you're thinking in base 10 so this
team in 2010 they won the competition by
factoring a 232 digit number so that's
how far we have come from from you know
Euler 2 or we can go back to Euclid but
from Euler to 2010 we're at 232 digit
numbers and here was the answer in their
paper so this was the first prime this
was p1 and this was p2 so this is the
state of the art right now okay how did
they factor this number and what is the
state of the art techniques well we're
gonna go back and build from the
beginning and this kind of defines
computational number theory that is the
topic of this adventure so what a
computational number theory mean well
computation comes from the Greek word
for gravel stones were used for counting
computation is any type of calculation
whether you're
using stones or a ruler or a slide rule
or a calculator or this cool-looking
machine which is Babis at Babbage's
Difference Engine which was a hand
powered calculator it doesn't matter
what you're using or you're using a
computer you're doing some sort of
computation and now what kind of
computation are we doing number theory
and that involves this mysterious
distribution of prime numbers studying
this distribution and what we're
actually looking at is multiplicative
number theory which is questions of how
do you factorize numbers how do you tell
me if a number is prime and so forth and
we begin with a very simple question or
not a question a challenge we need to
build a machine which takes an input and
that input is some integer X and all
that machine needs to do is output true
or false and that is the first step now
we will use the computer science tool to
actually build this machine together and
one of the questions that will we will
be asking is two things two aspects to
this machine how much time that's a
clock how much time does it take to give
the solution and how much space does it
need and when I say space I mean for in
the case of this mechanical calculator
physical space how many rooms do we need
to hold our machine or if we're using a
computer how much memory does it need so
we will be returning to these two ideas
as we go